hello hello good news you have been
pre-selected for a free cruise you're
right actually
Johanna this is a warning the robo
caller uprising has begun you cannot
escape us now press 2 to hear more you
won't win robot well just this year
alone we have made over 10 billion calls
to phones in the u.s. we're making calls
at a record pace and we're mutating some
of us pose as aggressive IRS collection
agents this call is officially a final
notice from the IRS the nature and the
purpose of this call is to inform you
that we have received legal petition
notice concerning a tax fraud against
you
some of us play more friendly scammers
like my BFF Rachel calling about your
credit card isn't she cute
hello this is Rachel at cardholder
services calling in reference to your
current credit card account there are no
problems currently with your account it
is urgent that you contact us concerning
your eligibility for lowering your
interest rates oh yes I think I knew
Rachel in high school didn't know she
became a Robo scammer good for her but
yes I've heard from all of those people
and on my smart phone why won't you guys
just leave us alone because technology
has made it so much easier for us we
start with lists and lists of phone
numbers then we just put those numbers
into a computer program over the
internet thousands of calls are blessed
at off in seconds the number you see may
look like it is a call from New York or
New Jersey but we can be anywhere in the
world I'm actually living in Boca Raton
we should golf sometime anyway good for
you but us humans aren't taking this
lying down
we've got the ammo to destroy you ha
like the FTC's Do Not Call list that's a
list for real companies we don't pay
attention to that thing I've
noticed but no we have other weapons too
first we're learning never to do this
interactive robo pests like you know
pressing buttons no talking I mean if we
hang up right away you don't know we're
real right yeah basically second we can
install caller ID and call blocking apps
like hiya when we get a call from a
spammer it will warn us and then we can
add it to a block list that's not bad
but you know we are always changing our
numbers but our best weapon a service
called nomorobo on landlines it
intercepts calls and soon it's coming to
Android and iPhones it sees when you
guys are sending out lots of calls or
spoofing numbers then it hangs them up
or tells us not to pick up yeah that's
going to be a problem for us but we are
not going to stop oh I'm sorry I think
you're breaking up by redial Joanna
redial redial al come on redial top
caller block who's in charge now robot